et
pierre bérégovoy contre attaque la ferté
chine et at il dit ne sera pas étouffé
le président mitterrand demandent que le
rapport de la cob quoi publier deuxième
affaire la société générale en
accusation sept fois samir traboulsi un
homme que l'on retrouve décidément
partout mauvais chiffres en des 30 pour
l'économie française
le chômage en hausse et un déficit de 4
milliards pour le commerce extérieur la
roumanie sous la botte de shao c'est
flou 71 ans ce jeudi un pays qui est
devenu la dictature la plus honte de
l'europe
la bande dessinée en vedette à angoulême
ouverture demain festival de la bd
deux cent mille visiteurs attendus
bonsoir
chaque jour il ya du nouveau sur les
affaires qui empoisonnent la vie
politique et économique
aujourd'hui vous allez le voir le menu
est particulièrement copieux en bref le
président de la république demande ce
soir que le rapport de la cob soit
rendue publique le ministre de
l'économie s'est expliqué ce matin et
ils contre attaquent la sphère de la
société générale ressurgit avec une mise
en cause par l'express de samir
traboulsi tiens tiens il est décidément
partout celui là vous me suivez toujours
alors reprenons dans l'ordre ce matin
pierre bérégovoy très offensif était
entendu par la commission des finances
de l'assemblée
une première car les journalistes
étaient présents pas question a dit le
ministre d'étouffer la faire une enquête
judiciaire aura lieu quoi qu'il arrive
claire chazal olivier dernière un
ministre sur la sellette
une centaine de journalistes une forêt
de caméras le grand oral de pierre
bérégovoy devant la commission des
finances de l'assemblée était pour la
première fois public
2h30 d'audition au cours desquelles le
ministre a voulu d'emblée mettre les
affaires sur la table avec un premier
engagement ferme rendre public le
rapport de la coop sur pechiney et
saisir en tout état de cause la justice
toute la vérité doit être connue il n'y
aura pas d'étouffement de ce dossier et
je considère que cette affaire d'achat
d'actions dans des conditions qui pose
problème et qu'ils peuvent en effet
supposer que ceux qui ont acheté
et à l'étranger ou en france disposait
d'informations
cette affaire ne sera pas est un fait et
pierre bérégovoy a pesé chacun de ses
mots en haussant le ton par moments le
ministre des finances n'a jamais oublié
qu'il s'adressait à des parlementaires
transformé pour l'occasion en
commissaire l'un s'est fait l'avocat du
diable
un autre a tout simplement livré le fond
de sa pensée commission salue son de la
démission de monsieur bubill à votre
place monsieur bérégovoy moi j'aurais
porté plainte pour la diffamation d'adn
et collaborateurs comme la loi de 1881
sur la presse m'ordonne de pouvoir est à
mon sens aussi le devoir
je suis un homme de devoir et je vous
regarde les yeux dans les yeux
mais tous les parlementaires avaient en
main les révélations de l'express sur la
société générale
pierre bérégovoy ne pouvait se dérober
il a ainsi promis ce que beaucoup
attendaient la cob at il affirmé se
saisira prochainement du dossier et
effectivement la sphère de la société
générale ressurgit on se souvient que
c'est roger fauroux le ministre de
l'industrie qui avait soulevé le lièvre
cette fois c'est l'express qui relance
samir traboulsi selon l'express aurait
acheté puis revendu cinq cent mille
actions de la société générale alors
mettons tout cela au clair christophe
martet 15 juin 1987 la société générale
est mise en vente
comme lors des autres privatisations du
gouvernement de jacques chirac edouard
balladur décide la constitution d'un
groupe d'actionnaires stables le fameux
noyau dur pour protéger la société
très vite barrister socialistes
contestent la composition de ces noyaux
durs et dénonce l'état rpr de retour rue
de rivoli pierre bérégovoy est
catégorique il faut casser ces noyaux
durs et c'est une tentative de prise de
contrôle de la société générale connaît
toute la polémique actuelle artisans de
ce dénoyautage georges pébereau à la
tête de mars aux investissements il va
racheter entre août et octobre 88
près de 10% des actions de la société
générale avec luis gustavo levens pdg de
périers jean-louis des cours patron des
chaussures andré françois dalle de
l'oréal et l'appui massif d'un organisme
public la caisse des dépôts selon
l'opposition cette opération dénoyautage
manque de clarté et pourraient cacher
des actions illicites et de confortables
bénéfices
il ya quinze jours roger fauroux
estimait que la sphère société générale
était d'une tout autre gravité que la
sphère pechiney aujourd'hui
l'information selon laquelle samir
traboulsi aurait acheté puis revendu
cinq cent mille actions de la société
générale avec un bénéfice de 2 millions
francs relance les spéculations sur un
possible délit d'initié qui vous avait
dit que c'était une bonne affaire
personne d'autre ce matin devant la
commission des finances pierre bérégovoy
a demandé à la corde que toute la
lumière soit faite
andrey je demanderai à la cob de
vérifier si les achats d'actions par
l'est personnalités citées si ces achats
d'actions ont été faits dans le cadre de
la légalité
là encore une seule chose m'apporte la
transparence et famille trabelsi un
homme que l'on retrouve partout on l'a
vu servir d'intermédiaire entre pechiney
triangle on l'a dit ami d'alain boublil
et le westie mise en cause pour la
sphère de la société générale décidément
rien ne se fait dans l'industrie et dans
la finance française sans ce financier
libanais mais qui est il vraiment hervé
brusini dominique tierces
il a des amis partout charles pasqua
propose qu'on lui décernait légion
d'honneur et c'est pierre bérégovoy qui
la lui remettra en octobre dernier
samir traboulsi est un homme précieux
pour tout le monde cela fait 25 ans
qu'il vit en france fils de bonetti
libanais étudiant en droit il s'installe
ici à paris à l'époque
samir traboulsi est associés au saoudien
akram auger l'homme qui dix ans plus
tard achètera le paquebot france
le bailleur de fonds c'est un autre
saoudien adnan khashoggi objectifs du
trio exporter du matériel français vers
les pays du proche orient sans exclusive
technologie arm travaux publics et les
affaires marchent pour samir traboulsi
il s'occupe de tout et même paraît-il
d'organiser les soirées privées de ces
très riches clients on lui prête le
surnom de vizir déplaisir mais qui dit
réussite dit jalousie en avril 80 de
samir traboulsi digne chez le directeur
de la maison dior en sortant du 75 bis
de l'avenue marceau de jeunes italiens
tente de l'assassiner
samir traboulsi est atteint à l'épaule
et à la cuisse
pour connaître le commanditaire de ce
contrat samir traboulsi fait appel à cet
homme francesco pia 105 italien proche
de la cia impliqués dans le scandale
politico financier de la loge p2
propriétaires de bateaux grand amateur
de tableaux de maîtres à monaco samir
traboulsi possède une suite réservée ici
dans cet hôtel à l'année
lieu idéal pour négocier toutes sortes
de contrats celui qui fut conseiller
pour les ventes d'armes de thomson est
aujourd'hui propulsé sur le devant de la
scène et sur le désigne comme bouc
émissaire à l'origine des affaires sa
réponse est toute prête pas beaucoup ce
rôle de bouc émissaire ce qui est
voudrait me faire jouer ce rôle ce 30
dates heures et comme je vous le disais
au début
le président de la république a donné
son feu vert pour la publication du
rapport de la cob sur la sphère pechiney
c'est ce que demandait le premier
ministre michel rocard
monsieur rocard a obtenu gagnent cause
de l'elysée alors cela nous amène à
reparler de la sphère eichiner avec ces
deux informations jean gandois le pdg
affirmé aujourd'hui que p chine et
n'avait pas payé trop cher les actions
de triangle c'était même une bonne
affaire selon lui deuxième info le
vendeur de triangle américain nelson
peltz semble bien avoir eu un rôle très
suspect dans cette affaire
confirmation à new york paul nahon
nelson pelle c'est peter may se sont
enfin décidés à parler par
l'intermédiaire du porte-parole de la
société trail en gueule
john sullivan les anciens responsables
de la société très engueuler nelson
peltz et peter mais ne sont impliqués
d'aucune manière et n'ont pas eu
connaissance d'une quelconque
utilisation d'informations
confidentielles dans l'acquisition de
triengen harper chine et nelson peltz et
peter mais démentent donc toute
participation frauduleuse dans cette
affaire cependant il est désormais
acquis que les deux anciens responsables
de triangle ont acheté une grosse
quantité d'actions juste avant le rachat
par péchiney ce matin de spécialistes
américains m'ont affirmé que ce genre de
manoeuvre était à la limite de la
légalité et que la s ici c'est à dire le
gendarme de la bourse américaine
auraient beaucoup de mal à prouver leur
culpabilité tant ce genre d'opération
était pratique courante dans le monde de
la finance
voilà enfin j'ajoute car les
rebondissements sont maintenant
multiples chaque jour que ce soir le
monde
enfonce le clou sur patrice pelât une
société suisse
experte à te rendes aurait acheté 20
mille actions triangle en novembre
dernier et selon le monde cette société
suisse aurait de multiples liens avec
projet patrice pelât l'ami du président
mitterrand vous me suivez toujours
eh bien c'est fini pour ce feuilleton
coty l'actualité politique maintenant le
ton monte à marseille dimanche vous le
savez c'est la deuxième c'est le
deuxième tour pardon de l'élection
législative partielle face à face
bernard tapie et guy teissier s'est
tenant du titre mais son élection avait
été invalidée
dimanche le scrutin s'annonce très serré
et c'est sans doute pourquoi sur la
canebière on s'échange maintenant des
noms d'oiseaux
roland sicard daniel les guy teissier
emploie les grands moyens
autocar escouade de couleurs des fiches
porte à porte
le tout orchestré par des professionnels
de la politique marseillaise en avant
marseille du ccif qui ne perd son
sourire que lorsqu'on lui parle de
bernard tapie épaulé par jean claude
gaudin le candidat de l'opposition parle
de fraude veut poursuivre son adversaire
en diffamation et résume sa pensée en
termes choisis
ce monsieur car une structure mentale
douteuses et bien amène le combat sur
des terrains mouvants
mais c'est assez triste et c'est
lamentable la démocratie ce type ne
m'intéresse pas ce que je pense c'est
que contrairement à l'image c'est
fighters qui voudrait se donner d'un
grand monsieur
eh bien j'ai découvert que c'est un
petit mec une campagne à la marseillaise
dans laquelle bernard très peace se sent
lui aussi à son ex le patron de l'om
joue les pères noël dans les cités
populaires parlent comme son adversaire
de tentative de fraude
et c'est rendre coup pour coup si c'est
pas des bonnes idées parce qu'il n'ya
pas l'hiver donc j'essaie d'avancer des
cité il est fait les poubelles des
immeubles pour voir si âpre et rugueux
lent chacun fait en fonction de ses
moyens et comme il a des petits moyens
et là des petites méthode une empoignade
qui laisse présager de ce que risque
d'être une autre campagne celle des
municipales le duel tapis tessier n'est
peut-être qu'une répétition la conquête
de la mairie de marseille s'annonce des
plus musclées françois léotard dans une
interview au monde le président du parti
républicain préconise une liste udf pour
les élections européennes sens général
du message de monsieur léotard il faut
rééquilibrer la droite pour préparer une
alternance de centre-droit dentistes
médecins pharmaciens avocats en colère
les professions libérales dans la rue
ils étaient plusieurs milliers cet
après-midi à paris à l'appel de leur
union nationale il s'agissait de
protester notamment contre les mesures
prises par le gouvernement sur le
déplafonnement des cotisations sociales
eve mettait les pharmaciens avaient
voulu le grand jeu un petit corbillard
étaient de sortie
censé porter en terre une pharmacie
moribonde
la baisse récente du taux de marges des
pharmaciens est accusé de l'assassinât
mais valeurs cotées aujourd'hui des
médecins architectes avocats notaires
tous protestent contre le déplafonnement
des cotisations sociales qui selon eux
menace l'équilibré de leur activité
c'est toujours sur nous conte comment
comprendre l'argent c'est pas compliqué
on pense jamais à nous mais c'est
toujours ça nous conte
quand on a besoin d'argent on nous mais
on nous matraque nous ne sommes plus des
catégories privilégiées du tout en
travaillant beaucoup plus présent et
notre venue à lens est devenu
totalement la servante
sur le trottoir certains passants ne se
sentent pas du tout solidaire je dis non
ils ont pas loin
cette plage de manifester parce que
j'estime que j'en laisse bien acier oui
en droit la manifestation s'est terminée
dans le calme devant le ministère des
finances la colère de demain ce sera
celle des profs grèves manifs ou
simplement assemblée générale les
enseignants du second degré mène une
action contre les projets du
gouvernement sur l'éducation
les projets lionel jospin malgré les
discussions avec les pouvoirs publics et
malgré aussi les promesses du ministre
est bien le malaise est de plus en plus
profond dans le milieu enseignant
voyez ce qui se passe au lycée michelet
de vanves manie catelan ici au lycée
michelet de vanves le message de lunel
jospin visiblement n'est pas passée et
après la déception c'est l'heure de la
mobilisation des enseignants tous
syndicats confondus en vue du mouvement
d'action prévue jusqu'en mars
tous sont unanimes pour dénoncer le peu
d'attention accordée à la revalorisation
aux conditions de travail déplorables et
à la surcharge des effectifs dans les
classes
si vous allez dans une salle de classe
vous voyez les fraudes qui d'année en
année
mon sens la charge de travail remontée
quoi n'en finit plus de corriger les
copies donc faire pèsent sur une
certaine morosité quoi si vous voulez on
est un peu un peu ras-le-bol quoi nous
voulons une réforme de l'enseignement
mais qu'est-ce qu'on a rien en réforme
de l'enseignement ça veut dire
augmentation des salaires pour
travailler dans de meilleures conditions
et être motivé
qu'est ce qui nous motive rien c'est ce
qu'on nous demande on nous demande de
travailler plus pour gagner plus ce ça
me paraît une évidence
malgré les démentis répétés de lionel
jospin
la rumeur concernant la revalorisation
des enseignants en mairie
s'amplifie et fait des ravages c'est que
cette histoire du mérite
et puis qui va juger de ce mérite c'est
un problème que je me pose des élèves
les parents d'élèves les inspecteurs et
qu'est ce que le mérite d'un enseignant
qu'est ce qu'un enseignant plus
méritants calme
lionel jospin a semble-t-il pris
conscience de ce malaise puisqu'il a
décidé d'informer chaque enseignant par
une lettre personnelle dans laquelle il
ré explique les grandes lignes de son
projet deux chiffres au chapitre
économique ils ne sont pas très bons le
chômage tout d'abord en décembre il a
augmenté de 1,4 pour cent en données
corrigées des variations saisonnières
après une baisse progressive depuis le
mois d'août il y a eu une flambée
soudaine aux derniers mois de 88 35
mille chômeurs de plus en un seul mois
au total deux millions cinq cent
quarante trois mille demandeurs d'emploi
deuxième chiffre le commerce extérieur
là encore c'est pas très bon gros
déficit au même mois de décembre plus de
4 milliards de francs en un seul mois
au total pour l'année 88 33 milliards de
déficit
le problème du commerce extérieur pour
la france n'est pas nouveau mais en fait
c'est toujours le même ce sont les
petites entreprises qui sont en cause
les grandes ailes elles ont pris bien
sûr l'habitude d'exporter
mais les pme n'ont pas toujours ce
réflexe ce but
maryse mano et pierre lepetit l'ont
constaté sur le terrain dans la haute
loire
reportage c'est ici à sainte sigolène
que l'on trouve la plus forte
concentration de pmi en france
pas moins de 50 entreprises pour 5000
habitants presque toutes transforme
plastique en sac tout vendu bénéfices
mais rares sont celles qui exportent à
sainte sigolène le handicap primordiale
je pense a été le problème des langues
étrangères
c'est un tissu de pme de sociétés qui
ont été créé par les gens qui
actuellement encore les dirigent et
n'ont pas vu la nécessité de s'orienter
vers l'exportation étant donné que le
marché intérieur se développer à un
rythme tel que
leurs affaires se développer sans qu'ils
aient besoin d'y faire appel paul
planchon c'est l'exception il a embauché
trois personnes à plein temps pour
s'occuper d'exportation mais il n'est
pas si gaudinois il vient d'une
multinationale ses collègues eux sont
sortis du rang certains sont d'anciens
ouvriers et pour eux exporter n'est pas
naturel l'école fait pas peur mais je
crois qu'il faudrait quelqu'un avec
quelqu'un qui prenne sa valise et haï
problème des produits dans ces pays pour
nous proposer tous les produits du
plateau et ses filets c'est notre
atavisme de france est on est on est
bien chez nous on était bien dans
l'hexagone
puis quand on se développer donc on
n'avait pas besoin d'aller à les galas à
l'export nous sommes une société famille
d'une seule famille au village les rares
patrons qui ont pris leurs valises ont
été poussés par la concurrence
c'est le cas dans le textile pas dans le
plastique cette fabrique des chars pas
investi pendant trois ans à l'export
avant d'obtenir le premier résultat ce
constat n'encourage pas les entreprises
voisines qui manquent souvent de
comprendre ça coûte cher ça coûte
beaucoup d'argent
il faut donc il est en quelque sorte un
apport financier exclusivement réservées
à l'exportation une espèce de bourse si
vous voulez je ne sais pas par quel
moyen peut-être un prêt sans intérêt
pendant trois ans remboursable
suivant certaines modalités si les
entreprises plaide coupable pour leurs
lacunes à l'exportation elle s'accorde
des circonstances atténuantes en raison
de leurs faibles moyens financiers
un argument entendu bien au delà du
plateau de sainte sigolène cette nuit en
principe nouveau tir d'une fusée ariane
le 28e il s'agit de mettre un gros
satellite de télécommunications en
orbite pour intelsat
au même moment succès commercial pour
arianespace la société va signer un
contrat pour fournir 50 fusée ariane 4
et oui dans ce domaine l'europe reste
très compétitive philippe duez avec deux
tirs parfaitement réussie en 88 la fusée
ariane 4 disponible en 6 versions
suivant le poids des satellites à placer
en orbite sera jusqu'à la fin du siècle
le fer de lance de l'europe spatiale
la commande de 50 modèles ariane 4
représente un marché proche de 18
milliards de francs mais cela montre
aussi une volonté commerciale très
affirmé cette commande se place dans cet
aspect ctive de réduction des coûts de
production nous cherchons près de 20% de
coûts de production en moins pour faire
face à une compétition internationale
accrue nous avons une expérience
commerciale dans ce domaine très
particulier qui est aujourd'hui unique
au monde
il nous appartient de la valoriser il
faut trois ans à trois ans et demi pour
construire une fusée ariane cat et cela
au tube 7000 personnes c'est donc un
contrat très important pour les
industriels chaque lanceur coûtera
environ 600 millions de francs un prix
en principe compétitif mais à partir de
cette année l'amérique revient en force
sur le marché des fusées classique et
les chinois avec la longue marche 3
propose des tarifs très séduisant or une
fusée civile ne sert qu'à lancer des
satellites et l'on peut se demander s'il
y en aura assez pour tout le monde
arianespace espère malgré tout conserver
50 % du marché
ce ne sera pas facile une foule immense
à varsovie pour l'enterrement du père ni
d'illac
le prêtre a été trouvée assassinée dans
son appartement le week-end dernier
il semble bien que ce soit un crime
politique une provocation ce même jour à
varsovie arrivée de lech walesa qui doit
commencer des négociations avec les
autorités
michel mon compte
dans le cimetière saint charles borromée
à varsovie
ils sont plus de dix mille à être venus
rendre un dernier hommage au père stefan
lippe bielak il y a cinq jours ce curé
de paroisse mourrait assassiné chez lui
à 74 ans tout autour de la fosse les
drapeaux rouge et blanc de solidarité
sur le cercueil
une phrase vous avez tué son corps
façonner ce prix là même épitaphe qui
est inscrite sur la tombe du père
popieluszko tué il ya quatre ans par la
police politique
ici tout le monde est persuadé que c'est
cette même police politique qui aurait
assassiné chez lui le père niedziela qu
le but des tueurs auraient été
d'empêcher la rencontre entre lech
walesa et le général jaruszalski si
c'est ça ils ont échoué
la table ronde entre le syndicat
solidarité le pouvoir se prépare
valaisanne est à varsovie
mais le père annette bielak n'est plus
là aujourd'hui pour le voir d'autres
informations de l'actualité
internationale à commencer par
l'évacuation de l'armée rouge
d'afghanistan elle se confirme pour
mi-février mais elle pose aussi des
problèmes
bruno roger petit
le retrait soviétique continue en
afghanistan retraite est loin de se
dérouler en bon ordre selon des sources
occidentales
harcelé par la résistance l'armée
soviéto afghane aurait même procédé à
des représailles sanglantes
conséquence des combats les habitants de
kaboul manque d'essence de pain et de
sucre et le ravitaillement organisée par
les autorités soviétiques est
insuffisant
le gouvernement rocard a tranché seuls
les pêcheurs de saint pierre et miquelon
auront le droit d'exploiter les
ressources de pêche de l'île le conflit
qui les oppose aux pêcheurs de saint
malo n'est pas réglé pour autant
le chalutier breton la grande hermine a
parié de boston à destination des zones
de pêche de l'île et à saint malo les
femmes de pêcheurs mal - ont annoncé
leur intention d'entamer une grève de la
faim
françois mitterrand a planté un arbre de
la liberté pour célébrer le bicentenaire
de l'accès à citoyenneté française des
juifs de france prélude à de grandes
manoeuvres diplomatiques au proche
orient
françois mitterrand souhaite en effet
rencontré le premier ministre israélien
ifrap famille autant de gestes en
direction de la communauté juive de
france
alors que le président français
rencontrera probablement yasser arafat à
paris dans les semaines à venir
la roumanie nous en parlons toute la
journée de ce jeudi dans nos émissions
d'information il faut dire que ce qui se
passe là bas en ce moment est terrible
un pays oublié où s'exerce la dictature
la plus extrême la dictature c'est lui
le président ça aussi ce coup il fêtait
aujourd'hui ses 71 ans dont 24 passés à
la tête du pays il est président il est
chef du parti
il contrôle tout et tous il est le
maître absolu c'est ubu de l'autre côté
du rideau de fer tout le monde commence
à rejeter sa hausse et ce coup même dans
les pays socialistes mais apparemment
rien ne l'arrête il a déjà rasé la
moitié du vieux quartier de bucarest
dans les campagnes
c'est la même chose il détruit les
villages voici les témoignages
recueillis par philippe rochot auprès
des réfugiés roumain dans les campagnes
roumaine une seule question sur toutes
les lèvres
notre village va-t-il être détruit cette
angoisse qui étreint près de 12 millions
d'habitants portent un nom le programme
de systématisation du territoire
objectif déclaré de ceausescu supprimer
les différences entre villes et villages
en clair logis et les paysans dans ses
appartements en mauvais préfabriqué des
appartements à la campagne l'électricité
n'arrive que quelques heures par jour et
où la température en cet hiver atteint
rarement 8 degrés les mauvaises langues
disent qu'en réalité s'ils ont détruit
les villages c'est pour mieux surveiller
la population paysanne en la regroupant
et en la coupant de ses racines de
secrétaire générale des verts
autrichiens raconte qu'il a vu des gens
obligés de démolir eux mêmes leur maison
certains se seraient même suicidé il
cite des dizaines de noms de villages
détruits dans les environs même de
bucarest et surtout dans les régions où
vivent les minorités allemandes et
hongroises plus spécialement visés par
la dictature de
ceaucescu les particuliers sont parfois
autorisé à restaurer leur maison mais
ils savent que jamais le pouvoir accepte
radia mené l'eau et l'électricité et que
la priorité sera donnée aux nouveaux
villages les paysans roumains doivent
donc accepter de voir leurs maisons
rasées
la mort dans l'âme il assiste impuissant
à la destruction de leur passé et ce
soir le magazine résistance à 22h20 sera
justement consacré à la roumanie
roumanie le désastre rouge exploit les
lancia au rallye de monte-carlo elle
était favorite mais elle ne se sont pas
contentés de gagner elles ont fait le
triplé premier l'italien byatt zone
devant deux français et le second en
effet c'est didier auriol l'étoile qui
monte dans les rallyes internationaux
thierry blancot didier auriol 29 ans
triple champion de france des rallyes
particularité n'avait jamais participé
au monte carlo
je pense que pour moi il est beaucoup
plus important de faire un très beau
rallye mais d'être deuxième à l'arrivée
que de chercher impérativement une
victoire dès cette première sortie avec
l'ancien la saison est encore longue
bosse modestie car avec un palmarès déjà
éloquent auriol a été engagé cette année
dans la meilleure écurie lancia
ambitieux il s'est donné deux ans pour
être champion du monde
style généreux il ne reste plus qu'à
prouver on donne tout le monde le même
matériel et les mêmes chances et ce sera
aux pilotes de voir qui sera le meilleur
en fin d'année en espérant que ça soit
un pilote de l'ancien par quelqu'un
d'autre ça on voit mal comment il
pourrait en être autrement pour didier
auriol en tout cas 89 commence bien
deuxième monte carlo ça promet pour son
premier championnat du monde
le dé d'or de la haute couture a été
attribué à guy laroche pour sa
collection de printemps c'est la
récompense traditionnelle des
collections c'était aussi le final de
cette semaine deux collections
parisiennes
un événement pour la mode un événement
mondial il faut le dire voici par
exemple coup d'oeil d'une américaine qui
a tout suivi avec une très grande
attention enquête marie-josée le picard
ou collection le vice-président de
bloomingdale bien ternes observateurs
cette saison c'est 200 millions de
francs que le grand magasin américain
dépense pour des produits français haute
couture chantal rousseau cherche des
idées
les américaines portent beaucoup de
vêtements du soir change beaucoup leur
garde robe du soir donc et nous dès
qu'il y a prestige c'est plutôt dans la
garde robe du soir que nous avons envie
de trouver un modèle étonnant et la
haute couture est par essence même
étonnant et puis il ya les couleurs avec
toute cette merveilleuse gamme des
jaunes des oranges et des rouges qui est
une gamme que l'on pourrait appeler la
gamme de gauguin
l'amérique s'intéresse aussi aux jambes
claire et hauts talons plats de chanel
accessoires qui détermine de gros
chiffres d'affaires
la haute couture confirme ce que nous
savons déjà une tendance vers la
féminité des vêtements diaphane féminin
une ligne trapèze qui a été présenté au
moment du prêt-à-porter en octobre
dernier la ligne trapèze de la croix est
parfaitement proportionné et ça c'est
important pour nous de voir une
présentation des proportions du bon
trapèze temps d'application parce que
dans le monde entier c'est l'image de la
mode haute couture qui fait acheter aux
femmes un bâton de rouge à l'air quand
l'actualité se dessine c'est angoulême
pour le festival de la bd
la bdc la bande dessinée bien sûr c'est
donc le dessin dessins d'actualité mais
aussi des saints de rêve
c'est devenu en tout cas un art à part
entière il attire de plus en plus de
monde il y aura angoulême
près de deux cent mille visiteurs cette
année en vedette les espagnols et les
algériens pour deux expositions
pascal deschamps michel perron reportage
un cheval enlisé dans le sable d'une
arène le décor est planté pour évoquer
40 ans de bande dessinée sous le
franquisme les historiettes à espagnol
vente les exploits des croisés des
conquistadors le métier paye mal la
censure est vigilante à la mort de froid
causé l'explosion
les dessinateurs découvre alors avec
délice la ligne claire belge ou lin dan
brown américain de la liste blanche et
une création
limite pour ainsi dire d'un côté ou d'un
autre de là je pense la richesse que
l'on peut constater dans cette expo pas
la peine de faire la grimace
la bd espagnol à ses stars connues dans
le monde entier elle s'appelle play et
rose torres ou prado son dernier album
chienne de vie est une chronique féroce
de la violence quotidienne
j'ai voulu sortir des stéréotypes
sociaux habituels
la violence n'est pas seulement le fait
des drogués des délinquants des blousons
de cuir on la trouve chez tout le monde
et partout dans la vie quotidienne
si la bd espagnol revient de loin
la bd algérienne elle n'a pas vraiment
encore décollé peu d'éditeurs peu
d'albums une exception slim dessinateur
de presse à l'humour corrosif qui attend
la relève
les bus est arrivé par exemple de faire
partie du jury où il ya eu des gens qui
ont envoyé des bandes dessinées de
l'intérieur du pays qui sont fabuleuses
cela dit c'est bien pour mes primes et
c'est tout la bande dessinée algérienne
une bd sur les starting blocks le
festival qu alger promet d'organiser au
printemps prochain donnera peut-être le
coup d'envoi n'oublie pas le tiercé
quarté + c'était à vincennes si je me
souviens bien voici l'ordre d'arrivée du
tir sedif faisait 5 vous laisse lire les
rapports pour le quarté ça fait 10 fais
5 et puis et puis et puis le 9 voix la
fin de cette édition du journal la
dernière d'abord tout de suite la météo
bien sûr n'oubliez pas résistance la
météo ce sera laurent cabrol résistance
présenté par noël mamère ce sera à 22h20
sur la roumanie dernière édition henri
sannier aux alentours de minuit et puis
n'oubliez pas 6h45 télématin avec
l'excellent roger zabel bonne soirée sur
antenne 2 à demain soir 20h
non